[Music]
this pandemic as you may have heard is
devastating the airline industry with
commercial air travel down nearly
listen to this number 70 percent from
last year that's a big drop
last week u.s airlines started
furloughing tens of thousands of
employees from the flight attendants
to the baggage handlers but so far delta
airlines has avoided any of the
furloughs
but more than forty thousand employees
have taken an unpaid leave of absence
and more than seventeen thousand
accepted early retirement and department
and departure packages without without a
new aid package from washington
the airline may now have to begin
furloughs next month
ed bastian is the ceo of delta airlines
and joins us to discuss this morning
ed always good to see you i'm sorry
though that it's under these
circumstances
so what needs to happen at your company
to keep employees on the job
well thanks for having me gail it's good
to talk to you as well
you know i certainly we don't know first
of all what's going to happen in
washington it's been a real roller
coaster these last
few weeks around stimulus and airline
aid as things
seem to change by the day but and i
certainly certainly hope for the sake of
the 30
000 airline employees in the industry
that have been furloughed
that they quickly get called back to
work but fortunately at delta our people
are amazing as they always are we call
it the delta difference
i asked them at the start of the
pandemic to do everything they could
to preserve cash to preserve jobs for
for each other
we had almost half the company take
unpaid leaves of absence throughout the
summer
all voluntarily another 20 percent as
you mentioned
took early retirement so as a result of
that they have protected their jobs so
for almost all of our work groups we
will not be facing furloughs
come come this winter we are still
working with our pilots union they are
the lone exception
hopefully we'll get to that same
position but for now at delta we've been
able to avoid furloughs
which is great that is really great ed
but you know the airline relief bill
it's not looking good right now what is
your message to washington to get them
to understand
how dire this is what is really at stake
here
well it's 30 000 jobs first of all for
those employees at other airlines that
have been furloughed that we want to get
back into the industry
it's about keeping our national
infrastructure in place
the airline employees have worked
throughout this entire pandemic
selflessly
keeping the airways open getting people
who need to get to places to their
to their homes to their loved ones in
times of crisis
and we think the the government support
which has worked for the six months
keeping this airline industry intact
has been quite effective uh but at the
present time the
the virus isn't where we thought it
would be when the first cares act was
passed so
hopefully the second extension will get
us into the spring and then we'll all be
hopefully in a much better place dealing
with the virus than we are today
yeah mr bastian it's tony decopola i
want to pick up on that last point you
know lawmakers in washington are worried
about cost and they're wondering if we
give you a lifeline
exactly how long of a lifeline is it
going to be how much money is going to
be involved
so what's your best guess at present for
when the airline industry will be back
to something like normal
well right now as gail mentioned we're
at about 30 percent
of prior year levels which is dramatic
much better than it's been in travel is
starting to slowly pick up
we expect for the upcoming holiday
seasons hopefully we'll get a nice bump
uh but as you look at confidence that
we're doing certainly at delta to
restore uh travel amongst customers when
you look at
what our customers are telling us about
their satisfaction which is an all-time
high
uh with the initiatives that we have
taken and you
look at that combination with the
advances in the medical field
around vaccines testing tracing
therapeutics hopefully in six months
time by the spring we'll be in a very
different place
i don't expect we'll be through this by
the spring but we should certainly be in
a much better place
to start to see real sustained recovery
mr bastian you mentioned you're hoping
for a bump around the holiday season i i
certainly hope that for you but you've
got the cdc telling people you know do
your thanksgiving locally
you know stay inside don't travel uh so
given that uh you know uh
how likely is it that in the near term
there's gonna be a benefit
well you know first first of all while
we say we're at 30
we still have a lot of people traveling
so at delta this week we're going to
carry a million people
so it's not as if people are not
traveling and i'm trying to cut you off
i i lost my train of thought there
in flight as you might say but i found
it again what i wanted to ask you is
given that the cdc is saying don't
travel for thanksgiving what is your
message to people about how
safe it is to get on an airplane today
people are still yeah people are worried
it's it's absolutely safe and i respect
the cdc guidance i
i talk to dr redfield all the time uh
it's not you know certainly if you're at
risk you should not be traveling
but that's not true for everybody we
have over a million people a week that
are traveling and it is entirely safe
you know there's a couple data points on
that uh just yesterday the international
airline
association came out with a stat and
that this year
on a global basis over 1 billion people
have traveled
in the air over 1 billion there are 42
documented cases of transmission
of the virus on board aircraft worldwide
and almost all of those were in the
first couple of months in january
through march
before masks were in place and before
all the protocols in place
and virtually no documented
transmissions over the last few months
at delta we don't have a single
documented transmission of virus
spread above our on our planes and we
are carrying over a million people a
week
so i think people need to understand and
look at the facts they need to make a
decision what's right for them
but the reality is air travel is
incredibly safe
all right is there a certain section you
should sit in that's safer than others
in the front the middle the back at
bastion then we got to go
gail i know you like sitting up front
and that's uh that's always i wasn't
talking about me
[Laughter]
is there a safe place to sit they're all
great thank you they're all great
students we all get these they're all
great they're all great
thank you